Let's translate various film terminology and best practices into those applicable to game development.
On the left is a list of various actors, components, and things Unreal Engine includes.
It's important to note that many of the items can be added to and manipulated within a sequence.
Control Rig, for example, is predominantly animated through Sequencer.
On the right are various terminologies we use when working with sequences.
Scene Assemblies are the complete encapsulated collection of actors, animations, and logic nested within a sequence.
Performance Takes is a feature that allows you to record animation from motion capture performances or input devices
using an iterative workflow to automatically record the motion to a sequence.
This tool is an extremely useful time saver in capturing multiple variations of a single shot and can be reviewed on the fly.
Takes can be swapped directly within a sequence via the shot properties from the drop-down menu.
Sets, Layouts, Staging, these all refer to the assembly of our actors in our scene,
or within our sequence via spawnables or swappables that essentially create the final look of our scene.
Level Sequenced with Shots refers to our graduated or parent sequences within nested sequences, or shots.
It's important to note that Shots are not a specific actor type.
In fact, Subtracks, Shots, Nested Sequences, and Parent Tracks are all the same actor type.
They're all sequences. It's how you use those sequences that really determines its functionality.
On the left are various stages or assemblies when working with traditional film practices.
On the right, we've translated those terminologies into terminology commonly used with Unreal Engine,
specifically when working with sequences. I won't cover each line, but I do encourage you to pause the video
and read through the slide to get more in-depth information and understanding how we translate film terminology to that that we use in Unreal.